r
2 Live
Why are there so many unbeautiful things in this world
and why I was born so beautiful?
I'm so lamented, I'm jealous of my beauty I don't understand that feeling I ca
n't help it Ah, it's a berry kimono, sushi,
my head hurts
I don't use dirty words with advanced tome. The
proportions are pretty beautiful.
I don't devote myself more to the example.
Is it okay? This team is
n't Mimosa.
It's
beautiful or it's too narcissist and it feels uncomfortable.
What are you saying? Mimosa I don't understand this beauty
.
As usual, the joke is hey, and the
upper row is more beautiful in Peros.
That's right, the sea is just like
me.
Even at the end, change the gaming that you took care of
me. Don't talk casually. Bob Tsue-I can't stand the mail that the ball's eyes are dead. The
atmosphere and behavior aren't beautiful.
Ugly yeah